these first two drills are just by
yourself
okay and as we said you have to take
fear off the table and
people that are
amidst chaos and fear other people scare
them the second you introduce someone
you're already triggering them okay so
these first two drills are by yourself
okay so the first drill is you can see
how you're decreasing
everything all the triggering
aspects for somebody you're going to lay
down
on the mat
and you're going to do corpse pose but
not be in corpse pose
you're more open
and release
and the first variant of this drill is
to do it
sharply and over exaggerating
an activation attention in the center
do not activate your arms
or your legs your center
that is currently releasing and relaxing
and dropping will
percussively flex
and release and you will let it go
all the tension it's in there
and when it's gone
and release at the beginning
you'll hold your breath that's fine
your change will be longer that's fine
it's all
fine what's not fine is this
this is me moving my head legs and
hands i don't want that i don't want
consciousness in them
i want my effort my intention in here
okay let's try it
so you're consciously moving your head
your head is relaxed
but you see it's stuck do you see that
that's your legs
so your feet are right now not connected
to your center
that that's a conscious movement of your
upper
shoulders and neck area which is why it
moved
don't you don't move your extremities
now the next drill
is taking you more and more
into the religious overlay so
i do have to have this relationship
so that i generate order
here represented by the extremities to
my center
but ultimately there's going to be a
center
to my relationship with okay
in other words there's going to be order
and there's going to be order to how i
fall
and all of those things are cultivation
arenas by which i either succumb to
the fear or i stay in the iq
okay so we're going to start generating
um the spiraling
aspect to this center periphery
organization
so i'm going to open my feet up
and i still right now i establish i'm
going to establish the order
okay and i'll first do disorder
so when i'm sitting like this
okay see my upper body is not related to
my feet
i'm going to use that percussive moment
of flexion
of the last drill to
prolong the order
here not like this
this disconnected order
and i'm going to pay attention to the
relationship between my head and feet
so i'm going like this my feet don't
move
my head is moving as as my head moves my
feet will get will be moving because
i'm keeping that order i'm not picking
up my lens
i'm locking it and my head is moving and
i'm keeping that order
okay we're going to go around in the
circle
and this is also going to give the new
student
the hand foot coordination
of the later break falls okay so
as my head goes down
and to my right the left leg is going to
stay in that relationship so left head
leg
head and right hand okay so disorganized
would be like this
organizes it goes together
and i'm using this to get up and to go
down
to get up and to go down so we'll do one
way i'm going around boom the pattern is
hand hand foot foot hand
hand foot foot you go and then you want
to go the other way
hand hand foot foot
your head stays in that relationship
with your feet in this relationship so
you see where my head is
stays there
keep your feet apart don't let them come
in
okay let's try that
so right there you you felt that little
right there
do you feel that yes okay so that looks
like strength to me
okay so we we have to condition to get
rid of that
there's no point in asking you
spiritually to remain ordered
if physically you cannot okay
but there's not really that much
strength in this drill
in terms of picking up your head why
you can use your you can counter yeah
you're counter weighting
okay so really what's happening before
you
have that strength requirement is you
disconnected
okay so try it again use your leg to
pick up your head
[Music]
separate your feet
so it's foot hand hand foot foot not
hand
hand feet all right separate your feet
change direction
do you see your breath getting
compromised
okay
i can do it like this
that's not it okay um
my extremities again have the same kind
of
unconscious
but uh you know flexion but my center
has
the percussive flexion now pull along so
don't as you're working it get rid of
the of the tension
in your body
now
[Applause]
it is not necessary nor practically okay
try it again
there's a lot of break and you first go
down
right there right there broken do you
see your foot didn't move
fading your back
breathe straighten your back
let's see the breaking break break break
okay so now i'm going to take that
organization
and kill a couple birds with one's stone
so the first one i'm going to use is uh
cesa it says not
disconnect like this okay cesar is
already
that organization in play
you're already learning and doing and
practicing
the very body organization that you're
using in your nagewasa and of course
in your campaign so you're already in
that relationship
so we're going to now extend that
relationship and take one component of
the last
drill and i'm going to relate and
generate that order by relating my
head to my foot so i'm going to take my
head
left foot right hand okay and
do one portion and start to learn this
back break fall
okay but it's key that i'm not
disconnecting not over tension
everything is just my body and i'm going
to experience
a slight feeling of falling and this is
where that fear comes in
and the disorganization comes in okay
but you were already falling in the last
row
so use your imagination to make this
drill like the last row
we're going to do back breakfall uh
mechanics starting with the right side
okay
so as my body comes out my head is
moving my leg will come out and this
would be
if i continue the last drill
incorrect would be this you can see i'm
segmented
so from cesa sliding out
lock tension won't out
my eyes will remain forward and i will
end with my head off the mat
and my feet up out
i get up i'm reversing that organization
out when i get up
i'm using it
to get up
from there you can uh introduce the
timing aspects of hitting the mat so
i'll do the same thing
out hands back in
[Music]
okay let's try that do both sides
okay in the first drill we had an on off
aspect to our center and the second
drill i kept it on
in this last drill i keep it on and
we're going to keep it on
um for a while because
that's the best way of teaching someone
but what we're going to do is start
seeking height
you seek height fear comes in you're
going to lose the order
and you're not doing you can be okay so
from cesar i'm going to go to kiza
but hon me again this is the front
i now teaching the back leg which is
what we use
to step into this spiraling geometry
that's going to be
used to throw me okay so both these are
on the mat
i'm on the balls of my feet the right
leg
marks the direction that i'm going to uh
be projected on a spiral and it also
marks
the inside hand which we used to hit if
we have it
but i'm going to do the same head and
leg relationship
as i'm going out i keep my eyes forward
out use the same exercise to get
up reset the drill so the beginner feels
knees down
feet it might for some it starts to
freak them out but obviously they're
still touching the mat
okay i do the same drill head starts to
go
leg comes out
okay let's try that one most of us okay
next drill you take
one leg up one leg up and it's the same
drop
one leg up
and this leg is lowering the head so
i'm not falling and picking the leg up
there's doing both
yes the legs coming up because the
head's going down but the leg is helping
to lower the head through the organized
center
okay let's try it mostly okay uh
this one both knees are up
i have that same box center goes down
the same way
[Music]
some errors come in because the momentum
is going to increase
and uh these are not martial and again
it's singularity it's division-based
this disorder is disconnect
so you're gonna go you'll see the extra
momentum
and you'll give your back don't give
your back as you get
same cesa upper body posture
still oriented this way still in this
l-shape to the line of attack okay
let's try both sides okay so what you've
done pedagogically is you've taken the
second drill
and you've just used it to try to
reconcile fear in the student as they're
going along
okay uh now we're going to start
standing but i have my feet in keys of
the last row
right now some people start freaking out
so you go no no it's like the last drill
you just go down
and do it
boom open your knees drop center lock
usually at this point you'll see the
beginner mistake but you'll see that a
lot of schools will
make this maybe intentionally even
because as they go down this leg's going
to roll in
and this is now going to keep their head
on the line of attack
that doesn't work run
because the back right ball kazushi
is on this spiral here it's not on this
one
oh i'm doing it he's going this way
and as i said there's a lot a larger
order there's the order
between his body periphery center
then the order between he and i and the
order between he and i
the attack and the throne okay so you
can't just
fall in the old way you have to
maintain this organization alright so as
i'm doing this drill
i open and i do the last drill the knee
goes this way
okay let's try both sides so
pedagogically i'm only
uh i'm only inserting the illusion of
height
because it drops down to the same other
level but it is enough to start
generating fear in the intestine now i'm
going to enter
introduce the illusion of momentum okay
so i'm going to have them start with the
right foot forward
take one step back into the last row
go down
and do the same last row so it's one
step
one step down
again don't let the momentum expose your
block
that's a no-no you're losing connection
with the noggin
okay try it both sides
okay now you're going to increase
the age the illusion of momentum and
you're going to
reintroduce agency okay
so they have to take the dashi has to
take at least
three steps and then they can decide
where they're going to go down which
foot
okay when they walk they walk straight
back
not in an artificial way
just straight back and when they decide
to take the fall that's when that foot
goes into the last drill
okay so you're walking
i decide down
walking down foot out
when they feel comfortable you can have
them pick it up
okay try both of those at your face most
of us find
uh a lot of comfort in our
controlling of the situation so we
that but that is not in kim the comfort
is not a chemi
the control is not a chemi
nor the fear that it's operating through
or because of
so uh what he's gonna do now
is push me with some energy
[Music]
you remember these days okay so he's
gonna push me i'm gonna absorb that
energy
in the number of steps that i end up
taking and i when i go to the fall
i turn the foot out and i do that other
drill
so he's pushing
don't let the extra momentum turn you
around
at this point we can teach how to get up
we use a triangle get up so
a little slower he's pushing i'm going
down
and it's just a standard jiu-jitsu
triangle get up
come up with your body post the hand
cross bottom hand and foot step out
up the end slope
don't use the energy okay give you a
block
and come around that's a no-no
push
okay let's try comparison
okay since i lose my agency to a degree
and the guy has control this is really
where you start to see the
disorganization
come in because the fear sets in the
darkness sets in and it
it's chaos it disorganizes things so i
started to have my center
moving with all my extremities moving
okay
so uh the other thing that we've done up
till now is we used a
static hold to generate strength and
coordination
but that's not really marginally
functional the first drill
where you have a percussive flexion that
is what we're after so we have to get
back now
to that if you look that kind of
happened here
because people are like loose and then
you have to find your center
so without them knowing it they're
already getting a kind of percussion
but oftentimes their solution is instead
to do it with a disconnect you see
instead of with the
foot head coordination and that does not
work because
when he disconnects his head is coming
forward
and if i was throwing him backwards his
head is going
backwards so if he came forward i would
be adding
force at impact to let's say a palm heel
strike or something
okay so his head has to keep going
backwards my head
goes always this way
i can't have my head go here with that
percussion
with that flexion my head is going
back up
so on this drill we're going to go
and hit that percussion from the
opposite extreme
because we don't want it we don't want
the head coming forward
so he's going to hold my hakama
and get me to extend my center the other
way
the identity can decide what they're
comfortable with
but the goal is to let it go let it go
as far as possible
so come up off your heels you don't
have your legs like this you're just
normal
he's holding me i don't have control he
decides
when he's going to let go that's when i
percuss
the center like the first drill okay
so he's holding me i give him my weight
and i go into the fall i get up
with the triangle get up
so here i'm not
so vertical like in all the other drills
i have a bow that i'm going to flex
like the very first drill we did and
i'll find my foot
okay let's try it a little bit more
flexion a little earlier
more double it
bring your head and limbs all forward
like the first drill
a little better
okay so you have all that control you're
still in control
that's a big response let yourself
hang in their hands
you see it's a little harder now right
you got to flex more
like the first one give your give your
body entirely to them
entirely to them
expose your throat expose your throat
let yourself come back
okay so i i don't it's very subtle
but do you feel it do you feel your fear
okay so you gotta get rid of that you
gotta open your throat more
like a human sacrifice expose your belly
expose your throat accept as you stop
stop
stop uh taylor take priscilla's spot
expose your throat there
okay everybody see how you see how she
tried to regain that did you see that
okay and that's not ukemi okay